Today, I'm going to
talk about my latest
project, the Dashboard
Builder, or how
to build Shiny apps
without writing code.
Now quick disclaimer.
This is not the UI Builder.
So yesterday at
the keynote, it was
a bit of an emotional
roller coaster for me
because I saw, oh, you
guys are doing UI builder,
I'm doing a dashboard builder.
OK, I'm just going to
see myself out, OK?
Nothing to do here. But I think
it's still a bit different.
So if I'm not from
RStudio, then who am I?
Well, I'm Peter.
I just finished my masters in
data engineering and analytics
from the Technical
University in Munich.
And in my free time,
I like to play chess
and do data visualizations,
especially Shiny dashboards.
Now, when I talk to people and
tell them about my hobbies,
well, most call me a nerd.
But there are also a
few people who say,
oh, visualizations, dashboards.
I would like to create
more dashboards,
but I don't know how.
It's I can't write R code.
It's too complex.
And then there are some
people who say, I could do it.
I know how to do it.
But I have so many great ideas.
I just don't have enough time.
And I think these are
all valid reasons.
But I'm here.
I want to tell you to
create more dashboards.
So more dashboards
like this one I
created about my
recent chess games.
Is this the most
sophisticated,
the most beautiful
dashboard you've ever seen?
Probably not.
I hope not.
If it is, go check
out the Shiny gallery.
Go check out some
Shiny contests.
But I still think that
that's a decent dashboard.
And everyone in this room
can build this dashboard
without writing R code,
without prior knowledge
of Shiny.
And you can do it in two
minutes and 22 seconds.
I know, but I can
prove it to you.
I have a video and you can
see the time on the bottom.
Right so if you open
up the Dashboard Builder,
you've created with
a blank screen.
And if you want to visualize
data, well, you need data.
So I downloaded some of my chess
games, saved it as a CSV file,
and then I'm just loading it
into the Dashboard Builder.
And then I could add elements
like a table about the date
and the results of my games.
And then I'm adding a graph
about my rating points.
So in chess, if you win
games, you gain rating points.
If you lose, you
lose rating points.
So I can visualize this.
I can add some value
boxes about the number
of games I've played.
The number is too high.
And my peak rating.
And then I can
add more elements.
And if it's too small for you,
if you can't see everything
that's going on, that's fine.
I just want to take
away how easy it is.
You don't have to
write any code.
And trust me, it's
also a lot of fun.
And while I'm here creating
the last couple of graphs,
the next part is the
interesting part.
There is an export
button up there
and once you click on Export,
the Dashboard Builder
generates R code.
It generates the R code that is
needed to build this dashboard.
And then it downloads this.
And then you can open
it up in RStudio.
And then.
You open up the file.
And once you hit, run.
Now look, it looks exactly
like the one we just created.
OK so now you have a
first impression of what
the Dashboard Builder can do.
So I quickly want to
say what it is not.
So it's not a standalone tool.
It's not Power BI, Tableau,
or whatever in R.
Why not?
I think these tools
are great, but there
are certain soft locks.
I think with every tool
you have the ease of use
versus the extendability
and power.
Now, this part is
highly opinionated,
so please don't be angry.
I think Power BI is easy to
use, but it's not powerful.
You can't do machine learning,
deep learning, serious data
science, or if you want
to do it, it's very hard.
And then let's look at
R. If you combine it
with HTML, JavaScript and
CSS, it's super powerful.
We all know what R can
do, but I would argue
it's not that easy to use.
So what can we do?
Well, we can use R and Shiny,
which is a bit easier to use,
but I still think there's
something up there
and I want to go up there.
What's up there?
Well, I think up there
is a WYSIWYG dashboard
builder. WYSIWYG means what
you see is what you get.
So if you have
R Markdown, that's not
WYSIWYG because you
have to build it.
So if you want to increase the
size of a picture in markdown,
you have to put in
width 50%, width 70%,
and then you build it
and then you can see,
oh, it's too small, so you
have to get back to the code.
If you compare this to
Powerpoint, which is WYSIWYG,
if you want to increase
the size of an image,
you click on the image
and you scale it.
And then that's how big it is.
That's what you get.
What you see is what you get.
But I also want all the
power and packages of R.
I want the data science.
I want the machine learning.
I want the visualizations.
So that's what I want.
A combination of these.
So why?
What does it add?
Who is it for?
And I think there are
two target groups.
The first one, beginners.
I don't think that
only data scientists
should create dashboards.
There are other sciences.
They have so much data,
so much insight that they
can use to create dashboards.
But it has to be easy to
use, because most of them
don't know how to write code.
And I think the
blank screen, when
you start a project,
that's really frightening.
So if we can help
them first step
without them having to
know how to program,
I think that's going
to lower the entry
barrier to data visualization.
And then there are the experts.
But if you just go to a client
discuss how the dashboard will
look like, that's
never going to be how
it will look like in the end.
So you create the
dashboard, then
you bring it to the client
who tells you, how
can we change this?
So you have to go back,
change it, go to the client.
Can we change this?
No. I want you to be there
in the room with a client
or maybe just with your team,
and build a rapid prototype,
build the dashboard.
So we're going to streamline
the dashboard building process.
So you have more time for
the really interesting stuff.
So now you're wondering,
how does it work?
If you open it up,
there are three buttons
and these three buttons are the
three steps you have to take.
You have to import data.
Then you're going to
build the dashboard.
And then you export it.
And then there's a
fourth open ended step,
improve and extend.
So we're going to import data.
With this module up
here, we can import data
from our R environment.
We can load external
files and Google Sheets.
Now, I did not create this.
I shamelessly stole it from
the guys from dreamRs.
DreamRs?
Yeah.
And once you've
loaded the data, you
can start to build
the dashboard.
Now there are two steps.
First, you create the element.
Right now, we support text
boxes, value boxes, data tables
and graphs.
So for text boxes,
just put in the text
you want to be displayed.
For value boxes, put
in a title, the value
and then an icon.
Data tables? Also very easy.
Just select the columns
you want to be displayed.
But how are we going
to create ggplots,
graphs without writing code?
And thankfully, the
guys from dreamRs
have this awesome
esquisse package.
I'm sure most of
you have seen it.
You see up there in the top,
those are all your columns
from your data, and then you
can drag and drop these columns
and to the x, the
y, maybe the color,
whatever, and then it's going
to create a graph for you.
And then you have this element.
And then you can.
Edit the content.
You can scale it.
You can move it around.
And you can also delete it.
And then just kind of repeat
these two steps.
So add an element, scale,
it, add an element,
scale it, add more
elements, move them around,
and then you kind of
build your dashboard.
And as soon as you're happy
with how it looks, export it.
And when you export
it, you get three files
you get the R project.
You get that data that
you loaded in as an Rds file,
and you get the app.R file.
And in the app there's
always a UI and a server.
And now let's look a bit deeper
into the UI and the server
files.
Let's start with the UI
for these two elements,
two value boxes. Internally, we
use the grid stacker package.
So we just add a grid stack item,
give it a height, a width, x y,
give it some ID, some
styling, and then in there,
please give us a
value box output.
Now we're going to do the
same for the second one.
And if that looks
a bit complicated,
if it was too fast, don't worry.
All of this is 100% generated
by the Dashboard Builder
and we also have the
same for server.
We're going to
render a value box.
Which value box?
Well, just this title games
played, the value is 200
and then we have
an icon and a width
and the same for the second
one. And again 100% generated.
But now comes to the
part where I have
to admit that I lied to you.
You do have to write
a tiny bit of code
because, look, the
value of boxes,
the values are hard coded.
So if the data changes, these
values will stay the same.
And that brings us to
the fourth and final step,
to improve and extend.
Now that you have
your dashboard,
you can do so much with it.
And in our case, let's
see, games played.
That's just the number
of rows of my data table.
And the highest rating? Well
the highest rating is just
the max of my rating.
So you have to write these
two tiny lines of code.
And I think most of us, most
of you, all of you, all of you
can do that.
And then when you've done
that, you get your dashboard.
Now I know what
you all want to do.
You want to use the
Dashboard Builder.
It's still in
alpha, but it works.
So you can get a
demo on Shiny apps.
You can go to my GitHub.
That will bring
you to my GitHub.
But you need for
both for the GitHub
if you want to run it locally.
And if you want to run
the apps that you created,
you need the grid
stacker package and you
can download this from GitHub.
I'm going to put it
on CRAN, but right now
you still have to do the
devtools install GitHub.
And then how can we all
improve the Dashboard Builder?
Well, I was a bit busy
in the last two months
because I had to finish
my master's thesis,
but now I have some free time.
I'm just job hunting, and I
want to improve the Dashboard Builder.
So please, if you have
feedback, if you have ideas,
if you have questions,
write me an email.
Open up an issue on GitHub
or just ask me right now.
Thank you.